now last night something happened on
this show
that shouldn't have been the least bit
controversial
but it sent certain hardcore fox-hating
liberals
into a complete frenzy so what happened
well two people from different political
parties
often times who fight with each other
well they actually discussed
issues where we found common ground
oh common ground gasp well our guest was
california congressman roe khanna a
progressive democrat
well the two of us disagree on most
everything well a heck of a lot at least
but we set that aside to focus on things
we agree on
mainly military spending and overseas
deployments
let me be clear i mean i was for the
strikes in afghanistan if terrorists hit
my country
we need to do that but i supported
president trump in getting the troops
out of
afghanistan i've supported president
trump saying we don't need the troop
presence in germany
there is a consensus that we are spread
out too far
and that this is not in our national
security
trump spoke to that coalition now in the
house
think about this neither the populist
conservatives
nor the anti-war democrats like connor
represent a majority on their own but
together
they can form a powerful voting bloc to
move
policy and oppose what may be coming
down the pike should biden assume the
presidency
now his foreign policy team is shaping
up to be far more
hawkish and more interventionist than
trump's
now regarding biden's nominee for
secretary of defense michelle flournoy
kana voiced
legitimate important concerns
she was for an escalation in afghanistan
she was for
iraq she was for syria these policies
have cost us trillions of dollars china
hasn't been in a war since 1979
we've been in 40 wars if you view china
as our biggest strategic competitor in
the 21st century then these policies
aren't what's going to allow america to
win
and compete absolutely and america needs
to focus
on our own country's needs especially
the challenges
after the challenges of 2020 my goodness
now many of us
across the political spectrum believe
that our party's foreign policy experts
have failed us for decades heck that's
one of the reasons trump won he's so
popular
and we're happy to find allies in our
battle to stop them from
selling us out once again congressman
khanna i would love to have you back
because i actually think there are
a lot of issues where republicans can
work with
progressives conservatives can work with
progressives and we'd love to have you
back as this develops
i appreciate that i'd love the
opportunity well
that moment was enough to blow the face
masks
off the crazies almost immediately
social media lit up
aaron rupar at vox tweeted i'm not sure
why any democrat would validate laura
ingram's show by going on it for a
friendly interview
but that's what ro khanna just did now
conor responded
please watch the interview it's about
cutting the defense budget and stopping
endless wars
i stated my position clearly and
consistently if someone on fox is
willing to talk about cutting the
defense budget
why not engage he went on to note that
great people like lincoln and dr king
were able to build important coalitions
in the past and said he believes in the
possibility
of overlapping consensus now the bottom
line is this the establishment in both
parties
over 30 years have gotten some big
issues wrong
iraq syria and china just to name a few
on the issue of endless wars prominent
liberals agree with trump's position
even if they most of them don't want to
give him credit
no great nation fights endless wars it
is time to bring our combat troops home
from the middle east
don't be fooled by trump's argument that
he's pulling u.s troops out of the
middle east or ending the forever wars
they're very worried that we are not
going to be involved in
endless wars i've signed a pledge to end
the forever wars
but honest liberals they have to admit
that trump's anti-war record over four
years speaks for itself
it's up to the grassroots in both
parties to push their leaders
into a more positive direction for the
regular working people
now republicans did that in both
elections overwhelmingly supporting
donald trump's america first agenda
and growing his popularity among the
voters
but democrats chose biden who on key
foreign policy issues
actually agrees with the old gop
establishment
so this is where the left-right
coalition makes a lot of sense
now here's a quick overview of where we
can actually work together
number one we can preserve trump's
tariffs on steel and aluminum which
would save jobs in those key industries
number two we could support the ongoing
anti-trust investigation into google
and push for other restraints to limit
the power of big tech
like repealing section 230. we could
oppose a trans-pacific partnership or
any other trade deal not supported by
workers
we can push for the strict buy america
rules for all government spending now
biden says he's for this
but this requires an important change in
the law as it's currently written
number five we could support a strong
infrastructure program
that will create jobs for americans yes
americans
and as congressman connor and i
discussed last night we can push to
bring home
all troops in the mideast and reduce our
military commitments that are not
directly aimed
at china this will mean of course
insisting that
europe do more to defend itself
now trump has done the right thing on
every one of these issues
and progressives who truly care about
working people will be wise to work with
us to advance these shared goals
as for the media everyone was grousing
about this interview last night
i still remember when they loved the
idea of everyone getting along
harry truman he believed
in the green light but his green light
was bipartisanship
calls for bipartisanship of course are
easy actually acting on them is not
does that still exist are there issues
that you talk to your colleagues across
the aisle and say
let's work together on this but
apparently
they only like bipartisanship when it
advances the causes the elites care
about
it's so obvious and so cynical and the
smart people see through this
progressives with integrity responded
forcefully to the haters who attacked
khanna for appearing on the angle
journalist zaid jilani said rokhana
shouldn't go on the most popular cable
news network to talk about cutting the
pentagon budget
what is vox's theory of change
transmitting information to the same 500
people in brooklyn
who agree with them over and over
bingo it's called politics and the point
of politics is making people's lives
better at least it should be
which means sometimes working with
people you don't necessarily like
is the squad by the way aoc plus three
are they capable
of shelving their hatred for trump
supporters
in order to improve life for their
constituents
we'll see the door is always open on
this show
and that's the angle